my daughter he's not herself right now
Dad it's happening to my daughter too
Mama I don't feel very
good following in the footsteps of Linda
Blair is an extraordinary
Quest violent
Tantrums spewing of evil
things I don't think there's anything
more
terrifying good day hey be home by
dinner I love you good morning Mr
Fielding morning
Catherine Angela and Catherine are
friends their families in a sense are
opposit of each other wherever those
girls went they brought something back
with them Catherine body in the blood
the body in the blood we're so afraid
that we wouldn't like get along I
introduced myself I'm like hi like
instantly we clicked oh yeah you have to
deal with a bunch of crazy people trying
to make a movie you need just quick
little peekaboos and go to school and
sit in a makeup chair for 2 and 1/2
hours a day
I remember seeing it and just thinking
wow and that's kind of when it hit me I
was like jge
Ro one girl lives one girl dies what's
better than one possessed girl but two I
mean it's just it's Insanity they made
me believe it they made me feel it I was
completely taken
in I don't want to go to
hell